I don't work for Google I don't work for
Microsoft I don't work for Amazon I
don't work at any of the places you
would think you'd need to work to do
kind of deep JavaScript infrastructure
and I never have I've never built
anything that would make you think that
I should be tackling a JavaScript
runtime in fact the most commercially
successful software I've ever written
was rails which is the opposite of a
JavaScript runtime which made makes me
wonder and you know maybe makes you
wonder but if you're too nice to say it
why I'm up here talking about this so
that's we're gonna talk about the answer
is a couple years ago a friend and I
decided we needed to find something to
work on we didn't like our jobs we
didn't like the company we were working
for we wanted to work on something that
that we could make good and we decided
to build a CDN which is something that
had been irritating us for a long time
so while I don't work at Google and
Microsoft and Amazon and and I've only
ever worked on rails I also get really
mad when tools that I am using don't do
what I want and so 22 months ago I think
I think that's exactly right it was it
was the CDN it's like CD ends are kind
of hot garbage are the same thing
they've been for the last 15 years they
don't really solve problems that I have
as a developer they tend to solve
problems that other people have that
don't make any sense to me and so we
decided to hey let's let's make a CDN
for developers let's actually solve this
problem and you'll notice I'm not
talking about a runtime yet so over the
next 22 months is kind of how how we got
to what we're talking about today so
when you decide to make a CDN the very
first thing you start thinking about is
you usually want a proxy server of some
kind and some local caching and anyone
who's ever used engine X knows it's
crazy fast it's quite crazy reliable
it's that category of infrastructure
that you just use you don't modify
because it's so good that the the
friction it takes to make it do what you
want is is high if it's if it's not
already nginx lets you script it with
Lua
so what we did is we sat down and we
started trying to build features for our
mythical programmer friendly CDN in Lua
which was okay except Lua and engine X
of a terrible program
model you basically write a giant config
file and you in inline your Lua with it
you hook into certain events during the
request it's not a fun thing to build so
two months later we wrote our own proxy
from scratch in go which is delightful
goes an amazing way to build Network
services we were very productive we were
able to ship a lot of features we gave
people a really cool web UI for hey this
is the this is all the different things
you can do with our proxy that we've now
built for ourselves that you can't see
the code for but you can just trust it
works really well and we immediately got
like hundreds of feature requests and
these are what I mean anytime you build
something from scratch you're gonna
guild you're gonna get a lot of feature
requests you're gonna get a lot of
things that you just shouldn't do for
people like really the answer a lot of
future Quest is no but this time what
happened is we got a lot of feature
requests a lot of different use cases we
were hearing and they were all legit and
what ended up happening I think is as we
were talking to our customers about this
stuff we sort of realized that they were
asking for a different level of product
than what we were providing basically
our customers were asking us for the
ability to implement their own logic it
wasn't it wasn't a thing we could solve
with the UI it was a thing that we could
solve by basically giving them a
programming language so it's like cool
we have this cool go proxy it does what
we want and we want to let people modify
it to there to for their own purposes
and so the very first thing we did with
our go proxy when we wanted to make it
more powerful for people is we started
looking at go based JavaScript runtimes
if you ever heard of these Otto's the
one we looked at really close there's
one called Gocha and what these are is
they're basically clean implementations
of JavaScript in go they're relatively
safe they're not doing low-level memory
management you're kind of immune to a
lot of the security problems you have by
letting people run code usually so it
seemed like a good thing to start with
problem is JavaScript is really slow
like really slow it's actually
ridiculously slow and and we all use
JavaScript and it doesn't it's not a
thing we think all the time but it's
it's actually pretty terrible if you
look at what javascript is doing when it
adds two numbers together this is the
series of instructions like reading this
takes 30 seconds it's just not a simple
thing that basically running javascript
code is very complicated
that basically there was no way we were
gonna give people anything valuable by
using javascript in this way
fortunately v8 exists and VA is very
fast in chakras fast and spider monkeys
fast basically the big companies I don't
work for the do build infrastructure
have built javascript engines that solve
a lot of these problems and it's it's
actually kind of fascinating how they
solved the slow javascript problem
here's here's what v8 does when it runs
your code this is the whole step and
there's one very very important thing
here which code generation what v8
actually does as you run your JavaScript
as its optimizing it is it rewrites it
in not JavaScript to make it fast so
it's it's actually again we're at a
level of thing here that I don't think
we can build so v8 very cool does a lot
of stuff needs to serious computer
science people why don't we see if we
can take advantage of this next step was
v8 and go which is not an awful idea
which just don't do it basically what
happens is go has opinions about how
program should work v8 his opinions
about pinion short or programs should
work it don't match it's a it's kind of
a disaster to try and run so a year and
two months later we finally said hey
let's just run v8 a node which is really
odd if you know anything about node node
is v8 plus io libraries plus some other
stuff we found a cool package called
isolated VM and what isolated VM does is
that lets you use node use javascript in
node to create new v8 isolates and a v8
I slit is basically the the virtual
machine that runs JavaScript NBA and it
what what was really cool about this and
in our in our you know our project
origin mythology story when I retell
this in five years it's gonna be like
yeah we decided to prototype this in
node with v8 cuz it was just the smart
choice but by accident it really was as
a node and is a really nice place to
prototype JavaScript runtimes because
you have all of this stuff there note
already controls v8 it's pretty easy to
hook into it and create new isolates run
your own code so I would highly highly
recommend you all trying this out if you
have any desire to build your own
JavaScript API at some point it's very
confusing for users but it works well
problem with v8 and the problem with
every javascript engine is they don't do
anything
so like the fetch function that we'd use
in the browser is really handy it's the
way we
do get h and make HP requests get data
from the internet which is kind of the
core of almost every program so when you
try and run fetch directly nv8 it'll
just say hey i can't run this i don't
know what fetches when you try and run
console dot log here's the api so what
you end up doing is you have to
implement the fetch API from scratch
which is a big hairy beast but at least
it's accessible it's a nice API but you
end up with what node let us do is get
straight to v8 and start prototyping
what we wanted our v8 our JavaScript
environment to look like for users
console log also does not work all the
Plumbing's there in v8 but if you run
console log nothing happens and the way
you can think about v8 JavaScript when
you when you put JavaScript into v8 to
run it is it's a black box it doesn't
affect the outside world at all it just
it just does some stuff in memory and
then it tells you it's finished and
hopefully you're happy with that you
can't require things there's no module
support you have to implement this stuff
from scratch or you can take the
shortcut we took for our prototype and
use webpack or something like that to
bundle files and just give it one big
old javascript but ultimately we were
able to build a set of libraries within
v8 that let people fork the CDN and what
what I finally realized way too late
like again startup origin story we're to
say this was our dream all along and we
start at the beginning and ultimately we
got there is that if we're building
something for developers it needs to fit
how developers work and I guess forking
things is kind of the the lowest level
way to tell if you're doing what
developers want to do developers want to
write code they want to fork what's
already there they want to modify it
they want to write unit tests they want
to do continuous integration they want
to do all of these things that you
wouldn't necessarily be able to do in
something like our UI that I really
liked but wasn't really useful for them
so that was cool and we gave developers
a way to do this we gave them an
open-source run time they could lunk run
locally got a lot of traffic and then
they've started building these really
cool things this is just a block of code
and what this is doing is someone has
basically made our CDN watermark their
images if they get basically if the
image is on their site there's no
watermark if it's if it's linked to a
third party site they suddenly get their
logo water
worked on it which has blew my mind I
think it was one of the one of the
happiest things I've ever felt is seeing
someone take something we built and then
do something with it that I just never
even thought of it's way beyond our
imagination it's one of the one of the
more rewarding things about actually
getting to this level of of what you're
shipping to people and there's a lot of
other things people have done with it
and our traffic blew up and we started
having problems and then we ran into
node issues this is a graph of our event
loop lag and if you've really ever used
node and anger you've probably been
irritated by the event loop at some
point what's happening here is if just
as a summary what happens the event loop
is if someone wants to be use a fetch
function what they do is they call our
native code the native code goes out and
does its thing and then it puts a
message back on the event loop to be
consumed later and so we're tracking
here is how long after something gets on
the event loop does it take for it to be
available to the code that uses it and
you'll see it's it's very variable it's
spiking very high it hovers around two
milliseconds which is really not that
great in the best cases and so what's
what's happened now is we've been
successful enough with what we're now
calling our prototype that we need
actually need to make this scale and
perform consistently so we can do other
stuff because once you get beyond HTP
when you start with talking about like
terminating SSL connections or doing
these other things that acedia needs to
do this type of performance isn't is is
just gonna be a pain so now we're in
hard mode so the next step after our
node prototype is to basically we built
in rust excuse me and actually we built
a lot of this in rust and extracted some
things from denno which if you haven't
see denno is Ryan dolls new JavaScript
runtime that he's trying to fix some of
the problems he felt like node had so we
we started using rust to create these
v8s and manage them because we needed
much more control over things like the
event loop we needed a lot more than
node with delivering and rust is really
nice and if you haven't used it it's
it's a it's incredibly performant has a
very strong type system and if if you
haven't used something with a strong
type system it takes a tremendous amount
of work to like start figuring out how
to use it and how to get the most out of
it but once you get there you can build
something like this which is
an example of a customer application we
have that is actually responding to DNS
queries and DNS is one of the most
latency sensitive things that happens
within the context of a CDN so the fact
that we've gotten to someone we can
accept a DNS request we can get an end
user code in far less than a millisecond
and then they can respond to the DNS
query means that we're doing a pretty
okay job with performance at this point
like I said it's hard mode the rest is
rust is very very difficult and very
very rewarding if you if you've never
used it so we built a runtime I like I
said I'm not the person he would have
expected you to do this thing and one of
the one of the big realizations I had
with all of this was that most of what
was preventing me from tackling
something like this it was it was all a
mental block we're all lucky enough to
work in this stack of technologies where
we can change every little bit of it
we're not we're not like trying to
modify a car here we're where we can't
actually go change out how the brake
system works we're building something
where we actually have the ability to go
in and make changes that we want to
every layer of everything that's
happening between us and our users and
the other really fascinating thing for
me as we've done this has been to just
compare the complexity of what I'm
talking about with like you're just a
general complexity of a front-end stack
so basically everything I just talked
about is pretty complicated there's
there's a fair amount of things we had
to learn but it's actually in my mind
it's it's simpler to put in your head
and simpler to understand and then your
normal react application is there's so
many moving parts in front-end like
we're all kind of used to this level of
complexity I think that the the trick
for everyone of us is to expand expand
our minds a little bit and get beyond
the rails or to react or whatever and
actually start making these tools do
what we want so not only did we build a
runtime but you can too
and because anyone can cook so this is
the end of my ratatouille theme but yeah
that's the that's it everyone can cook
JavaScript
[Applause]